andre is just a uh i mean
oh wow boy uh he's a he did his phd with
the home chimpkin who is
another one of my absolute heroes and
andre's
one of my newest heroes so we worked
together when i was a um
am i visible we worked together when i
was uh
visiting nrel during 2018 and uh
yes i mean i will waste your time he
works on topics as you can see on this
uh
on this slide um
good all right thank you uh thank you
yeah thank you again for yeah thank you
for inviting me to present
in this excellent event and i i show
here this first slide
and you can see the beautiful colorado
mountains you can see also the
wind farm or wind turbine in this case
that sean was so excited about
unfortunately i will not talk
about wind turbines in this talk but um
definitely it's an interesting uh topic
that um
an application for for this
reinforcement learning methods that we
heard today so it would be interesting
to see how this can be applied another
thing that you can see here is also the
date which is wrong but at this stage
i mean probably september fourth or
third doesn't matter every day it looks
the same so it's
some part of yours of course
and sometimes yeah exactly some people
have september 4th already so it's good
okay so what i will yeah so so what i
will
talk about is on what i call here
real-time system optimization
and you will realize very soon that this
is
just online optimization in the loop to
a physical system so this is
this would be the main um the main theme
for this
uh for this talk uh and
yeah i hope you can hear me well because
sometimes i have internet problems so i
just wanted to check that
the voice is fine and perfect okay
so first i would like to thank also the
collaborators on this
work these are the main collaborators
uhn who is now
and he was former sean's student
uh aditya devraj and shawn and we have
also other people that contributed to
some of the things that i
show here like i will mention them in
the middle but
the main focus of this talk is about
what could be called real-time system
optimization and to describe
this setting is quite simple setting at
least conceptually
is the idea is to look at a system
physical system that is described by an
input output relation like this where x
represents the vector of controllable
inputs why
collect the system outputs and ht is a
algebraic system model and and here
the model is assumed to be time varying
and i will tell you in a second also
again the example the running example in
this talk will be power systems this is
the main topic of application of
national renewable energy lab where i am
but you can imagine the application of
these approaches to any
physical systems so i will write this
as an input output relationship like
this but you can also think of a more
general case where this relationship is
implicit
and and the
vector of outputs is determined by a
system of
algebraic equations rather than rather
than by
an explicit map and this is also the
case in many systems like power systems
for example
but for simplicity i will just write a
relationship like this
so let me straight uh go to the example
or the application that i will also show
in the end
for people and i'm sure people here most
of the people may not
know what exactly power system is or how
you describe it but actually
it can be described very simple by
at least for our purpose on this slide
by a network
on the left side so basically a power
system looks like this it's a graph
that represents a connection of nodes
via edges
nodes are some nodes in the power
network
and edges are transmission lines that
transmit power
and the nodes here especially the nodes
that are highlighted
represent the nodes that can be
controlled so basically what we can
control
in the power system in this particular
example we're controlling power that is
injected by
different devices in the system into the
network
so you can think of solar solar panels
batteries electrical vehicles
and your appliances homes that are
injecting or consuming power
so basically x will represent in our
examples the net
power injection which means for example
if i have a house and positive value
would mean
how much power is injected if the value
is negative
it means the power is consumed so this
is an example
of what is the controllable device in
that system or controllable
variable the why the output in such a
system could be for example system
voltages this would be
again the running example but all
different quantities
in this system that are important for
system operation for stable
and efficient operations such as
voltages currents
uh you can imagine other things again i
will focus on voltages for
simplicity and this map in ht
is actually the famous power flow
equations which is a combination of ohm
and curve laws roughly speaking so you
can imagine that this is a set of
algebraic equations
that determines the system voltages
given
power injections and this again in power
systems typically this is an implicit
relation but again i will just for
simplicity assume that this is
an exact uh explicit map
in other words i will assume a single or
unique solution
of this system of equations given
the input and the third
the last aspect that i wanted to
emphasize is the time varying aspect so
as i mentioned here this map is uh
dependent also on time
and this represents the fact that
different elements in that system
are time varying so you can imagine that
there are different loads here
and different elements here that are
uncontrollable and they are just
injecting or consuming power
based on their own criteria based on
their own
algorithms that you cannot really
control and these represent
uncontrollable elements
therefore these are kind of the noise in
the system
so that creates time variability in this
map in a standard way
another time variability comes from the
fact that sometimes this system
may be reconfigured in real time in
other words the topology of this network
or the
graph that you see here will change
essentially meaning that you have a
different
constraint a different constraint input
output constraint
and therefore again this map can be time
value
and here for illustration i show also
how the load and the
solar generation look like in those
systems so you can see here a profile of
loads
in 24 hours this is um
showing of course this famous famous
shape of the load
where i have the peak in this second
half of the day
and the second plot here shows the solar
power that can be generated by
solar panels in the system and again it
shows
kind of more or less sunny day where
there are no clouds but you can imagine
also
different curves here that are much more
noisy because of
clouds in cloudy days
so this is kind of the the example of
power systems really again is
in one slide there is a lot of uh
thing behind this but in order to
obstruct the problem that we will be
seeing
today and give you an application
example i think this is enough
so we're talking about optimization so
really what we want to do in
these systems and the power system
example is one example
uh is to optimize the performance of the
system in real time
and i give here very simple example of
optimizing
some cost associated with the output y
subject to constraints and the
constraints i again for simplicity i
divide it into two constraints again
we can add more things here and i will
add more things in a couple of slides
but to illustrate the concepts i think
it's enough just to consider the
constraint
the explicit constraint on the input
and this could be for example
engineering constraints on the
devices that you have in the system for
example a solar
panel can only produce between
zero power and maximum power available
from from solar at any time t
and you can also notice that this is a
time varying set because
solar of course as you also saw from the
profile here
is a time wiring profile
maximum power this you can view it as a
maximum available power
and moreover again during cloudy days
this is very
volatile so it's not um it's not very
smooth so it can change abruptly in
seconds basically
so this is the first constraint here the
second constraint is basically physics
right you say okay
you you optimize your output subject to
the connection between y and x so that's
um that is the simplest form of the
problem that i will be considering again
i will also complicate it
in a few slides and to make it more
practical
so again the running example is power
system so i just
tell you what is the classical example
of optimization in power systems this is
called optimal power flow
in that case what you're trying to do
you're trying to optimize
this is again very high level uh
definition i will define
exactly mathematically what it means but
roughly speaking what you're trying to
do is to optimize generation cost and
customer satisfaction in the system
subject to device constraints and
physics and physics here will mean again
these powerful equations that i
mentioned before kirchhoff
laws so yeah this is
this is just to give you an idea what
optimal power flow is
i will give again the full definition at
the end when i will show you
the numerical example
so let me start with a couple of um
slides that talk about what can we do to
actually
optimize this kind of systems in the
real time and let me start with very
simple
idea which i'm sure you all will agree
with that simple idea but i have to put
it on the slide to make sure that i
what i present next makes sense so the
first idea is really to just solve
problem one right so basically what
happens you have a time varying
optimization problem
and you just take your system model ht
you compute maybe it's jacobian function
jf matrix jht and you solve problem one
for example using
projected gradient descent solve by
solve i mean of course
in a generalized sense uh you of course
using a gradient descent you will only
arrive
at maybe at a stationary point or kkt
point depending on
some conditions on the different
functions that you have here
if the function f is convex and h is
linear
and set x is convex then you are
guaranteed to converge to
an optimal solution by running this
projective gradient method and of course
you can run
any other algorithms that you fancy but
uh
that's just for illustration here and
that will go
yep yep so the different time steps are
not
connected together by anything here
so yeah yeah that's an excellent
question so in this case i'm considering
kind of this online optimization setup
if you wish where we
have a sequence of optimization problems
that are
indeed just like repeated games right
where you don't have a connection
between the times are we going to come
at a regret or something like that like
the best decision in hindsight right
points are so yeah there are two
criteria regret
as as all probably people know here and
the second criteria that will be
discussed and i actually will show
results on the second criteria is just a
tracking error
so how far the
decision produced by an algorithm is
from the optimal decision at that time
so uh these are the two criteria
so what's the difficult this is a true
online problem what is being observed
what is known what is not known
yeah yeah i'm kind of confused about
this
so i will yeah i will tell you in a
second yeah so let's for a second assume
that you know everything
okay i'm just saying this is just the
baseline right if you know everything
here
in problem one you just solve it right
that's that's the only thing that
happens
projected gradient method like you just
like optimize for every single time
step t and that would give you you know
the best possible solution for every
single time step t
yeah if running uh gradients uh
uh projected gradient what not then you
would lose compared to that
surely yep yep yeah so so yeah
that will be on the next slide and and
that i will talk about the
online or
yeah yeah yeah i i i i yeah so so to
clarify again what i show on this slide
is really very stupid thing is just i
say i say
i okay i have a pro problem one if i
have infinite
computational capabilities if i know
everything and if i can run projected
gradient method to
infinity i can just solve the problem
and arrive at the solution so that's
that's probably not very interesting
what is interesting here i think
is just a structure that i want to show
here and this is what i
i will talk about in a second to get or
connect to online optimization and to
this model-free online optimization
basically eventually to gradient-free
optimization that sean presented
in his talks so so basically the
structure that i just wanted to to
emphasize here is the fact that since we
are optimizing this system
with this um input output relationship
it looks like this right we have
a gradient descent where we have a
jacobian of the input output map that
multiplies the gradient of the objective
function
and the objective function is evaluated
at h t of x which is the output of
the system at the previous iterate right
so this is just from
chain rule right it's not very
surprising here
so my point here is that for systems and
and we are talking about this real-time
system optimization where i was saying
and i mentioned before that we have high
volatility of resources such as solar
high voltair loads basically in order to
solve this problem we actually need to
solve
this problem every second in real time
and large-scale systems network systems
is becoming
more and more problematic so basically
just the solution of this problem in
real time is uh not feasible
typically and second this is to your
question sabra is that
what is what is typically happening in
these systems is yet that you don't have
a lot of those elements
in real time especially i will
in this case i will focus on the case
where what you don't have is really the
model
uh we assume that you kind of as we
assume that we know that our objective
function which is a bit different from
maybe machine learning typical machine
learning online optimization
approach where that what is unknown
typically is just a cost function here
it's there is a bit of a structure
where it's more it resembles maybe
enforcement learning where or right
because where we
in the enforcement learn of course we
have multi-period problem but here we
have a single
period problem or steady state problem
but what we don't know
exactly is this map ht
yeah so that's we also have a question
from rene
uh what happens for x and y
what is the story the dimensions of x
and y
so that's a excellent question so i i i
again it depends on the system but you
can imagine in that kind of system of a
power system
x represents all the controllable
devices that you have in the system
and depending on the system if i give
you a typical system if you take bay
area san francisco bay area for example
you will have millions but uh
of course uh typically what you would do
you will subdivide the system into
subsystems and you would do some
hierarchical control
and optimization where you optimize
areas in the system
and you may take hundreds to thousands
of inputs
which represents controllable devices in
the power system
and then the output could be similar it
depends on how much
remember the output here that i
described in the power system
was the voltages voltages could be
depending which voltages you want
to what that you care about
at most you will care about the voltages
of all the nodes in the system so the
size of y will be the size of the number
of nodes
in the graph of the network system
network system that you have
and similarly for x right at most it
will be the size of the
number of nodes basically uh but yeah it
could be of course
less depending on what you can control
and depending on what you can measure
and what do you care about in terms of
outputs
eventually
so i hope this answers this
um so so basically so yeah i'm just
coming to this
subtle point that says okay here if we
want to do it it's not only that we need
to
solve this problem in real time but we
also need to know the model and again
this is kind of the
common theme in this enforcement
learning i guess
boot camp is that we are trying to do
something from data right or
in that particular case what i
talk about here is that i am moving from
this open loop or feed forward
optimization approach
to
feedback optimization what do i mean by
feedback here is
it's a bit vague when i say it in the
title but the idea is shown here in this
diagram basically what i do i put the
optimization algorithm in feedback to
the system
and here go you also see the online
suddenly right so
instead of solving the algorithm solving
the problem
since anyway i cannot solve it and maybe
i don't have to solve it especially if
it changes fast
so what i could do is really to do that
our famous online gradient descent right
so
equation two is just online grading
descent the only
subtle difference here is that since i
have this system in in the loop
i have this term here this is what i
want to emphasize so when you we talk
about this system real-time system
optimization what we talk about is this
feedback interconnection
where the the
online iteration of the optimization
algorithm acts
on the measurement of the output at time
k and now k is identified with the time
and not iteration actually so basically
you are
in this particular example i'm doing one
iteration at every time of course we can
think of doing more than one but
this is kind of the extreme case where i
do one iteration
and again here you can again i'm still
assuming that i know f
so maybe again a bit different from
online
learning online optimization in machine
learning
where maybe you assume that you don't
know f at time
k i assume that i know it but what i
don't know really is this relation
between y and x
instead i just use the measurement and
this is
looks very simple but conceptually it
creates um feedback interconnection
and there is of course then all the
questions associated with stability and
of uh of basically control theory
questions that
arise when you do that so
still one thing that i want you to
notice here is that although
now suddenly by the way notice that it
becomes model free
almost right because if you compare to
if you want to do online optimization
with using this iteration
you need to know h right but if you
close the loop and you are able to
measure why
you don't need to know h you just need
to observe the output and
go to the next iteration and if by the
way the problem
i'm sorry yeah yeah to know the jfk
the check okay yeah so excellent so
that's my point here
right so although by doing that we
closed
the loop and we made it almost all
model-free
so still it's model-based because you
need to know j
yeah and j represents in some sense
sensitivity of input
of output respect to input right so this
is something
that in practice for example in power
systems is a bit less
problematic to obtain but still
it requires knowledge of the model
um the good news is that because it's
feedback here
and because um any inaccuracy
in y will be corrected by this feedback
loop
even if you have inaccurate j this
algorithm typically works
provided that j is almost in the right
direction
but again uh you cannot know it in
advance
and obviously it is becoming even more
problematic when j changes abruptly and
j can change abruptly for example
if uh in this power system
for example we change a configuration
and we change i don't know
here i didn't show switches but imagine
that you have switches in this graph
that
make the topology of the system
completely different
in that case j might change abruptly and
sensitivity of one node with respect to
other node might be different
uh from one time to another time
so this is yeah so this is the main
disadvantage
in this approach is where you still need
to know j
and this if i if you
if you agree with this slide i guess
this motivates the next
slide which again probably will be not
too far away from what you already heard
from sean
and the idea is to replace the gradient
so instead of going to this gradient
first order algorithm we can go to and
apply zero order approximation
of this function so here i'm talking
about this
uh composed function of uh f of
output of as a function of x and again
you have this gradient here uh that
represents
that we have the chain rule with the
jacobian so instead of computing this
gradient like this
what we propose is to use zero order
approximation and sean already showed
uh all these different variants so let
me just come back
in this slide just to list some of the
options so the first option that sean
showed what was uh i think one a in his
in these slides was a single function
evaluation again this is very
people that know bandits optimization or
extreme seeking will
know this right this is how things are
typically done in this literature
and this requires a single evaluation
of the function at a perturbed
input and the perturbation here is using
some exploration vector c and
a control parameter a controlled
parameter small scalar epsilon
the second variant that also shown sean
showed was the two function evaluation
which
basically looks like numerical
derivative
uh in generalized to the vector case
and there are also other options where
you increase the number of evaluations
and you do an average of those and i
didn't show it here but you can imagine
how you can increase
the number of evaluations to to
improve the accuracy of these kind of
approximations
so in this talk i will focus on this two
function
evaluation approximation again you can
think of others
the main motivation was also explained
by sean i think
so one motivation is first of all that
if you do the like the taylor series
expansion and if
everything is really ideal here in a
sense that you
do this exploration at the same time
step
right so it's a bit of an approximation
of course once you do one
input you apply one input x plus
and you apply other input x minus the
system already may be changed but
assuming that the change is not
big enough then um you can
implement it otherwise you need also to
account to the variability in the
function in between the two evaluations
but but let's assume from first for a
second that it's not happening
so one good property is that this
approximation is actually looks like
this right is this low rank matrix
times the gradient plus an error term
that is of order of epsilon squared and
actually if
we have a quadratic objective function
this term is actually zero so basically
it's
uh it's even better right so this is one
um
one
motivation for for using these two
evaluation the second one
is that it has nicer properties than
single evaluation
shown touched upon those i think in his
talk first of all it has smaller
variants
it has lipschitz uh properties right
because
if you look at this especially for
uh for the case where this epsilon this
term is zero you obviously see that this
uh approximation is has the same leap
sheets properties as
the gradient which is typically a
standard assumption
in any analysis um and
uh yeah there are other advantages
and of course we can take more
uh evaluations and do averaging but of
course this requires more evaluation so
this is becoming more
computationally complex to implement
so i will focus here on this kind of
practical case where you assume we can
do these two evaluations it is enough to
have nice properties
and fast convergence but of course
people can think of just standard
bandit optimization where they use this
wire and
as well and this this works in practice
with a bit slower convergence i would
say
and what i will show for power systems
will be based on this
this approximation so
with this approximation i guess i
convinced you that we don't need any
more anything in this interconnection
loop
right we don't need any more of this
jacobian we don't need any more of the
mapping
hx we just need to be able to
approximate this term
with um something like that
by the way um can i have a quick
question clarification questions
admit this approximation uh where you
have this
uh big lapse on square term it seems to
suggest that you should just make
epsilon go to zero that's not true
right um right right something is
missing here
yes so i mean you can you can see
that if you take epsilon go to zero
obviously
this uh becomes
right if you just look at the equation
uh there is
this term that goes to zero and this
term goes to zero right so
uh in principle you could take
epsilon go to zero but as far as the
convergence goes here to of this
denominator nominator i think you will
have a problem in um
i think something we should like the
variance right like
this right like speaks to that
unexpected right so there is a trade-off
between uh
right so there's a trade-off between the
var and i didn't i didn't show it here
but
it will appear in rates actually so
uh obviously yeah if you take the epson
to zero you will have
as usual you have this trade of there
between the you know the transient term
and the
the term where you convert like the then
if you see the
the symptotic neighborhood of the
optimal solution
and you will have a try a trade of but
yeah i didn't i didn't
mention it here but obviously yes if uh
if you have uh
epsilon 0 it will not work
so okay so yeah and i'm happy to take
questions in between that's uh
just let me know um if there are
questions appearing that
i don't see them so what i wanted
yeah okay so what what i have on this
slide is
i will not go through this you can
imagine that there is tons of
literature on uh gradient-free
optimization in general
including from the history that
sean was talking about from 100 years
ago more or less
and extremum seeking is one
method that looks like what i show here
and uh you have uh of course spal and
uh even in the beginning of 90s
which is similar idea
spsa and uh recently there's a lot of
work on gradient free optimization and
bandit optimization where
again very similar concepts are used but
the bandit optimization there and
this type of literature the show here is
more on machine learning
applications where there is not really
system
in the loop and extreme seeking is
actually
very close in spirit to what i showed
here so
because it talks about adaptive control
and what is what we are doing here is in
some sense
a way of adaptive control so
uh so the focus of this is about
first of all i want to yeah the focus of
this presentation is about
uh constraint problems so i'm talking
about constrained time varying problems
and i will go
into uh more detailed definition in a
second
and the idea as you saw in power system
example is to show power systems or in
general network systems and how we
control them
in real time the second point here is
deterministic exploration so this is
coming back to
sean's talk about quasi-stochastic
approximation
sean i think motivated quite a lot of
why
using the deterministic exploration
signal the signal c that you showed
rather than
as the stochastic one
and um the third point here is about
practicality right what we're trying to
do here really is something that can be
applied to this large-scale system such
as this power system
therefore we are looking for online
distributable
light let's say methods and you will see
we will be talking about primal dual
methods and
you will see an application to power
system in more detail
so let me go quite fast on this slide
it's not too interesting it's just an
extension of
this basic problem that i showed before
but to a system a network system so we
have n
subsystems that are interconnected by a
network again this is the actual example
of power system this is how power
systems optimization problem looks like
problem three where you have n agents
that can optimize uh their own
power injections such as solar panels
batteries or aggregations such as houses
right and they have their own
constraints
operational constraints and then there
is a set
of constraints imposed on the system
output
right so this is just an extension of
the previous problem where i also add
constraints on the system output as well
as costs
in terms of system input
and knowing optimization we can define a
lagrangian
of this problem right let me just go to
the next slide
and um what we're trying to do here is
or maybe yeah
what you're trying to do here is really
to define what is the optimal solution
so under technical assumptions
uh if you formulate the saddle point
problem for this
problem for uh then
x star and lambda star uh
the optimal solutions of this saddle
point problem uh coincide with the
problem
solution of problem four at least x star
coincides and understands optimal
lagrange multiplier
so what we are doing here is uh like
regularizing
and uh there is a motivation behind this
so i'm not just taking a lagrangian here
i'm taking a regularized lagrangian
so like regular lagrangian is this term
i don't define it because i hope you all
know what it is
but what i add here is two
regularization terms these are standard
uh
l2 or tcon of type regularization terms
that make this lagrangian
strongly convex and strongly concave
strongly conducts in x slowly concave in
lambda
assuming that everything else is convex
and so on and so forth
so and the reason behind this
regularization
is kind of practical to make convergence
much
faster than in cases where you don't
have these
strongly convex or end concave
properties
so from now on you will forget about
problem four
but you will just remember that z star
is the optimal solution of this saddle
point problem
so this is our desired trajectory of the
system
and the online algorithms are trying to
track this desired trajectory
and the as shall we mention in the
criteria will be
a regret which i will not show today uh
but in this particular case it will be
just a tracking error between z star
and z that is produced by an online
algorithm
so the online algorithm that i will be
talking about is this
primal dual algorithm where at each time
this is kind of standard primal dual
algorithm
with some simple twists again feedback
that i will show in a second
but uh yeah i just divided it into steps
to make sure that we are
connecting to the real system so it's
not just an optimization algorithm
remember it's an algorithm
that is in the loop to the real system
so what we are doing at every time
step k we are applying input x k
we collect measurements of the output y
hat k
we compute the gradient
of the lagrangian with respect to x
we perform the primal step we perform
the dual step
and we repeat okay again i will not go
into the details of this because this is
kind of a standard primal dual algorithm
online primal doom algorithm but what i
want to emphasize here is again is that
this
feedback thing right so in a standard
optimization that will be it but here
what i'm trying to say is that actually
we are closing the loop and what we put
here
in this terms is the
system output or measured system output
what y hat
and again this is the model based
version right because you see i still
using the jacobian
so it's model based in the sense that it
requires
to know what is the sensitivity of
output respect to input
now as i showed in the previous slides
for the simple problem we can
in the same way extend the zero order
algorithm to this setting where we need
to explore right we explore
at x plus epsilon c and x
minus epsilon c again here i assume that
we are able to explore
at the same time step uh
without moving to the next time step
otherwise we can do also the other one
which makes the analysis more
complicated of course
and we collect these measurements
again here i also assume that i apply
to the system a third input x k which is
in the middle this can be also avoided
we don't need to do it but again for the
analysis it's much easier to assume that
we also have
x k as the actual input to the system so
we just perturb
plus per term minus and then we go back
to
to the to the actual x again means that
we have three
three three evaluations but
if we have two we can also do three in
some sense
and once we have all this we can just
replace the gradient part
that associated with the output with the
zero order
terms i don't go into the details but
you can imagine this is just an
extension of
this um zero order
keyframe of all of its uh or other
names that you can think of to
this problem wherein the lagrangian will
displace the gradient associated with
the output
with these terms and again primal step
is the same and dual step
are the same the only difference is that
the primal step is now with approximate
gradient again see look
just notice it's still a feedback
interconnection right because what we're
using here
is really the measured output of the
system
rather than the
an output that you could compute from a
prototypical model of the system that
you might not have
in real time
so i will go quickly about the analysis
uh this again so you can imagine
since i'm talking about this uh
quasi i mean you can think of this as
quasi stochastic
gradient descent like what sean
presented
it could be put up to some extent in the
qsa theory
but it can also be analyzed at least the
convergence
it could be analyzed directly
especially in this case i'm showing you
the conditions for direct analysis where
we are using
constant step size notice that opposed
to what sean showed where he had these
vanishing step sizes in this particular
case we are using a constant step size
and there are several motivations behind
that one motivation is because we are
talking about time varying problem
it makes more sense to use constant
steps as
although again depending on which metric
you are using
for example for regret you could use
also a time
a vanishing step size maybe something
like one over square root of t
but for that work i assume here
that the step size is constant small
constant number and i will choose a
constant
step size to have some guarantees on
stability and convergence
so some assumptions i will go quickly
over that first assumption is
on the exploration signal this seems a
bit restrictive again this can be
relaxed
for simplicity i'm sure in this one it
talks about
the sample covariance
of the exploration signal remember i'm
talking about this
deterministic signal such as the
sinusoidal signals that sean mentioned
and under some assumptions you can make
this the identity actually we don't need
identity we need
positive definite matrix again for
simplicity assume it's an identity
it could be achieved by using some
sinusoidal signals and
taking t be some
common integer multiple of the periods
it's a bit of restrictive assumption but
again we can relax it to
um some assumptions where you
have a positive definite matrix and that
still will work
the second assumption for analysis only
is that we have some issues with
projections i have to say
in in these algorithms right remember
that we have all these projections here
uh the version that we have now and
actually we have no
other versions but for the for this talk
what i have is is a version where we
assume that the projection is not active
at every time step but also only
these big d time units again this can be
relaxed
but let me just put it for analysis
the third is assumption of variability
this is just telling us how
far uh this or how how fast
or how much the optimal trajectory
varies so let's start i remind you this
is the optimal
primal dual pair and we have a bound on
the variability of that
we have a bound on the availability of
gradients and
similarly for other functions again
notice these assumptions a bit more
restrictive than the regret standard
regret analysis but this is because i
will be
talking about tracking results rather
than a regret result for a great result
actually much more relaxed
assumptions can be imposed to get a
result but let me just show you that one
and finally since i was talking about
measurements remember we have a
measurement of
output then we need also to assume that
some something about the measurement
error
and for that particular case we assume
that this is just a bounded
measurement error um you can also assume
stochastic
standard stochastic assumptions on them
and on the error but
for that one we assume just bound ui on
the measurement error
and then there is this um stability or
tracking result
that tells us that if you can choose a
small enough step size alpha
and um that basically yeah the only
thing that you can
um basically uh tune here is the steps
as alpha and also this parameter epsilon
but
mainly parameter alpha that will
result in a bound asymptotic bound
like shown here where alpha is a step
size again
this var epsilon is of order of
different parameters that i just defined
of alpha of epsilon squared e f e y
sigma i remind you this is the time
variability of the optimal trajectory
and c will be less than one if you
choose alpha accordingly
and again this result doesn't show
this trade of with epsilon and with
alpha obviously
yeah you can take alpha equals zero and
that seems like it would work and
epsilon
it will not work because of the
transient term that i just
omitted here for simplicity but yeah
this rate here of how fast this
converges to this
will be affected by the different
parameters here
but the overall idea is that in
asymptotically you will convert to a
neighborhood of
this trajectory um
and the upper about really the worst
case bound will be something like that
this is and this is based on analysis of
the primal dual method that i showed
before
which becomes actually an approximate
primal dual method with this
zero order approximation so this kind of
standard analysis
and this result can be interpreted for
example as just a stability result that
says that trajectory
uh input to state stability
these kind of types of results
so i have some time uh
left in the left in the remaining i will
i will not go into the proof i mean
there is a paper in ecc that we
prove this result and we also are
looking into how to also feed it into
the qsa
um you can imagine that it's doable but
it requires a bit of more work
in terms of the assumptions that shown
presented in his work
and in the remaining time i just really
want to give you an
example of the application because i
guess this was kind of the main
motivation for my presentation here
is to show what we can do with these
things and this is i think it's kind of
exciting and one example that sean was
talking about the wind example of wind
farms
is interesting the example that i show
here is what we're already doing now
is how you can optimize in real time
different devices in this power system
that i showed you and you can see here
is a bit more complicated example with
123 nodes so you can see here 123 nodes
in this particular simulation we only
had 11 controllable devices but this is
easily extendable to
much more devices that you can control
the rest of the devices were just
uncontrolled and you can see the
uncontrollable elements again
um these this is the driving signals for
those elements such as how load looks
like or how the solar looks like
and another thing that happening here in
this example is that the network
actually can be configured as i
mentioned before
so in the middle of the operation you
suddenly can have a new topology a new
graph that represents this system
in other words this function h there
that i showed changes
also because of that
so optimal power flow remind you what is
it what it is
it's really optimizing the cost of
different elements here such as uh
generation cost
customer satisfaction subject to physics
constraint and device constraints
and this this is explicit definition of
those device constraints in particular
case of this power systems optimization
again i don't think it's maybe not very
interesting
going into details of physics here so
i don't want to explain to everyone what
is active and reactive power because it
requires
another one hour but you can imagine
that these
devices the solar panels that you have
they can basically
you have two knobs there one knob is the
active power which is just a regular
power as you can imagine that can the
solar panel can produce
and there is another knob which is a
reactive power which helps to do other
things it doesn't do much for
for energy but it can for example help
with voltages in the system so you can
turn this knob and you can turn these
knobs and there is an
interrelation between these knobs there
are some constraints that are shown here
uh without going too much into these
details but i do want to tell you what
are the objectives so the objectives
really
are two two main two objectives one
objective
is to uh
[Music]
what could be called emulate a virtual
power plant
out of this feeder so in other words
think of this
sorry the term feeder maybe people don't
know what it is okay
think of a neighborhood in a power
system
where your house is connected and this
is the system of the neighborhood
and think that you want to make a
virtual power plant
basically of this neighborhood by
controlling and optimizing the different
devices in real time
in other words what we are trying to do
is to dispatch this
feeder or this system and
make it follow a given power signal at
the connection point of this system to a
larger grid
so instead of using a regular power
plant you're kind of creating a power
plant out of them
of a collection of devices that sits in
people's houses
so this is kind of the idea of virtual
power plant is very popular now
with all this massive penetration of
the resource forces
such as solar and batteries and so on
and so forth so this is one goal is
really to follow the feeder
head power this is what is called what
is said here you are just trying to
track
a given power set point for the power
that flows
at the connection of the system to the
to the main grid and the second main
objective is regulating voltages so
while you do that you have a constraint
on voltages
so you want to keep the voltages within
press specified bounds
and you can think of these two as
constraints on the output of the system
so once you control the system you put
you tell the solar panel to inject
certain amount of power or you tell your
battery to inject a certain amount of
power
this will result in certain voltage in
the system
and in a certain power that will flow in
the connection of the system to the grid
and this actually is the system model
right that we don't know in the power
system
because of different elements that i
described before
so we can see here some of this behavior
that i told you before
if you don't do anything to the system
this is what you will see this will be
the power
that will flow at the connection of this
network
to the grid and here i show example of
two networks
uh remember we have two configurations
of the network i didn't show
it here but i actually by two
configurations i mean that
i have two possible configuration of
switches in this network
and we have these two modes here
one network one and one network two and
you can see that
on the voltage side so this shows the
voltages
you can see that the voltages becoming
very different when the network switches
to
a different configuration
and from the operating perspective from
the optimization perspective we don't
know those things we don't know when
this
switch happens we also don't know what
is the configuration
of this network the only thing you can
do we can only measure
these outputs these two outputs
in that case and do something
with that with these outputs as i showed
in the this feedback interconnection
so for example the output here is one
number for power
and there is a lot of numbers for
voltages because voltages here represent
all the voltages in the system
and this is what happens if you apply
this algorithm the primal dual online
algorithm basically you are able to
track
a given signal so this step signal is
the signal that we provide
so this shows kind of the virtual power
plant we are able to
make this system to follow a given power
signal
and we also able to regulate the
voltages within bounds so in this case
we wanted to impose lower bound
constraint on voltages which is 0.95 you
just think of this voltage as a as a
normalized value between 0 and 1 and you
need to keep it between
above 0 and 95 so this algorithm without
knowing
that we had this reconfiguration without
knowing what are the actual
system elements so what is a system
model was able to
regulate the voltages within bounds in
real time
and finally what i want to say
uh yeah i know that i'm running out of
time but what i wanted to say is
there is some question about noise here
right remember that we have measurements
and all these algorithms will be
sensitive to noise
so depending on how much noise you add
to your measurement you will see
deterioration in behavior what we
observed is actually there is certain
threshold behavior that could be
explored also analytically we just
observed it numerically so far
that up to some level of noise in
voltage measurements and power
measurements you have very good
behavior of this interconnection but
after some threshold there is a fast
deterioration in performance
and luckily this bound here or this
threshold here is
above the standard measurement noise
and typical measurement devices
but uh but yeah it's it's still
interesting to see why we have this
interesting behavior like that
so yeah i will stop here i just want to
say yeah this is the summary i know that
we
probably we wanted to have some time for
questions but
yeah i will stop here and
take any questions thanks
um so there is one question
that came from gaga uh he's wondering
about
whether the tracking error is going to
imply something about
constraint violation error constraint
violations
yeah that is it's very good question
yeah thanks uh
actually so the tracking error that i
show here
is both on primal and dual variable
so it implicitly implies
things about constrained violations
however there is also a way to analyze
the constraint at least we analyzed in
some instances also directly the
constrained violation
and showed bounds on constraint relation
as well but in this particular result
since z includes both lambda and x it
just tells us how far we are from the
optimal
primal dual pair and um assuming that
when we close to
optimal primal dual pair we also close
in terms of
constrained relations but but yeah i
mean the the analysis of constrained
relationships should be done
in addition i would say if you want to
have an explicit vowel
yeah um an unrelated question that i
have
uh how far are we from deploying
algorithms like this in the vibe
yeah yeah yeah no please go ahead you
wanted to complete yourself
no it is just like is this already
uh deployed or is it going to be
deployed or
what are the things that need to be
addressed before you could
you could deploy something like this
so the quick question is it is quite
close to be deployed
in a sense that what you see on this
slide is
going currently into some
commercialization
um again this here and the difference
between this slide is that we use
jacobian and we don't use jacob in
another one but
um yeah so so
in terms of applicability and
where we are here in the up in the
demonstration of this we are kind of
quite far now
the problem so let me show you where we
are now so we demonstrated it
on um real microgrids in california
and we demonstrated it on a reels
distribution feeder here in colorado not
in the mountains
actually the the the co-op that the
electric cob that operates
one of the ski resorts and
it is moving forward the only problem is
that
utilities which kind of the
natural customer of this kind of
algorithms are not very forward-looking
generally
let's say so it's very tough to
to you know to push something like that
to them unless they
really see why you need it or what is
going on if you don't do it
and they gradually see the need for that
especially
when you have more and more these very
fast acting volatile devices on the
system edge that you need to control and
coordinate in real time
but it takes time so to to go further in
this process you need
some time and understanding from
utilities or you need companies other
companies like i don't know
tesla google that will take over
and will do those things instead of
utilities so
and it's going there as well to some
extent so
i guess in parallel we are working both
with utilities
which is again it's pain usually and
also with some
companies that are a bit more
forward-looking and they are trying to
use back doors to
deploy those things without really
directly interacting with utilities
and we have some some some recent yeah
so easily we had a company that was
interested in actually
deploying these algorithms because i
mentioned that these algorithms can be
distributed right so you basically want
to run
the instances of this iteration for
example when you distribute it
between different agents in people's
houses for example right
and one one thing that we're doing now
is we are partnering with
smart meters company because smart
meters are
very extensively installed in people's
houses you have this smart meter it
doesn't do anything there but it has
computer
that sits in your house and can
basically perform these algorithms
so we are trying to partner with them to
push this through smart meters and kind
of
telling utilities oh by the way you
already have this right you don't need
to do anything you just need to
run software and see how it works so
it's um
it's kind of a backdoor approach to
utilities
okay uh so just talking a little bit
around this
applicability so the time scales that
you're looking at like
what are the optimization steps or
optimization
scientific time
so here the motivation behind this loop
here was really fast
scale so what we are talking about
is really second seconds so
we assume that we do this so yeah if you
go if you really want real
numbers and like real units then
uh we do it every second or 100
milliseconds let's
say whatever time scale but this is kind
of the ballpark
we apply to the system seed output
basically this loops have to be closed
in this kind of seconds time scale which
means that we need very fast
measurement capabilities as well in that
case and compute it
well uh compute yeah yes that kind of
leads to
uh the distributed
um applications or
distributed implementations i guess uh
because maybe on this time scale
it is a bit challenging to implement a
centralized algorithm
uh so what are the challenges if you
want to to distribute this algorithm
there is
it is written as a centralized algorithm
here but
yep yeah that's that's again
yeah it's it's exactly the line of
thought that we have now
in terms of how we scale it and the
scalability is
dependent a lot of this distributability
and
the one version that we have now that is
kind of the
more commercial what we're trying to
commercialize is
this gather and broadcast i i can i
don't have the the figure here but
you can imagine the idea right so this
iteration here if you think of this as a
cartesian product of individual
constraints of all the devices
you can just distribute it right so you
can just write it for each
uh each element and right
and then what you need is to communicate
to these guys here x
i let's call them right i mean i have i
think i have it here right so
basically right this x i can be computed
locally
projected locally the only thing that
you need really to communicate is
lagrange multipliers associated with
network constraints because
because whatever everyone does affects
everyone else right
so so in terms of the output
a current one standard approach is
really this gathering broadcast what it
means is that you have a central
entity that is able to measure
the outputs of the system or gather this
measurement which is fine this could be
like for example a
control center of uh utility they do it
now already and they get your fast
measurements of voltages
uh they compute this iteration this
iteration is very light right it's just
nothing here um and they send this
lambda down to
basically broadcast the vector of
lagrange multipliers to all the devices
and then every device does its own
optimization based on the element of the
lagrangian with
taking into account the lagrange
multiplier
and this is kind of the standard
we call it distributed it's not really
distributed because it requires a
centralized
entity um this is one approach let's say
the simplest one
conceptually at least uh and also of
course we are looking into more
consensus-based
approaches where you don't have this
central entity but you have these
measurements
that can measure things and they can
communicate between each other so they
can
communicate lagrange multipliers between
neighbors and basically propagate this
information so more like a
consensus-based
implementation of these algorithms
i and it a lot depends also on their
actual architecture that you have in
in these utilities and the power system
so
yeah if you have a central entity like
utility and it can
gather measurements and it can broadcast
this lagrange multiplier then then you
can
do it but if you think about completely
distributed case where there's no
like uh master slave yeah there's no
master slave right it's just everyone is
just doing
something then it's more like
consensus-based
approaches that could fit here
all right uh we do have some questions
on a q a
uh have you tried various forms of this
injected inputs the
uh what was sinusoidal in
the case of sinusoid yeah so
so in this in this case we tried
sinusoids
we also tried uh before going into this
we also tried
stochastic uh perturbations
and we saw these effects that um that
sean showed on these slides where you
have
much more noise and much slower
convergence
so we went so that that was the main
motivation to go to this
deterministic perturbations especially
since we're talking about uh
real-time implementation where you need
to do these things
fast enough to cope with changes in the
system so if you
if of course if you let the system to
converge and the conversions will happen
in
one hour and maybe the system already
changed so we don't
we want to have really fast convergence
and it showed that this basically that
we could see that this
signals led to faster convergence and
also when using this thing uh this um
keyframe also it's let's say
idea uh it was also faster than using uh
and less noisy than using the single
evaluation
that kind of kind of standard bonded uh
idea or
uh zero order i guess here here the
question is like how much did you
explore like
frequencies for this sinus so it's how
much does it impact the result
how do you change this yeah so yeah we
explore different yeah so so the
frequency should be
fast enough to yeah we explore those i
think what we showed here is more like
um
uh one of the optimal results based on
this exploration so
of course i didn't i didn't get too much
into this but you can see that this
convergence rates here so for example
this shows how fast you are able to
to bring the voltage back into the
bounds
uh right so here of course it shows it's
very fast but if you zoom you see that
it takes some time
so based on this um exploration of
frequencies of the signals and the
magnitudes of epsilon and everything
yeah it was more like a
trial and error i guess for the
simulation
um to see what works best but
yeah i don't i don't have exact details
because the simulation was under uh
it's not here but i i know that we need
a lot of exploration for
for how to choose these parameters how
to choose these signals and
we can give you more details if you ask
the time
yes need to be imaged uh in general
would be the idea uh so there was also
uh the question it's somewhat related to
this times
clear question that you're assuming
simultaneous measurements multiple
simultaneous measurements of the outputs
which is not
uh feasible in this application or other
applications
uh so how do you deal with that like um
do you have any thoughts about uh
whether we could refer to the single
measurement
or just push through the two
measurements not caring about
uh that uh the system might have changed
a little bit
yeah yeah that's good question so indeed
these assumptions kind of say that
within the time step
uh the season didn't change right so
and uh i mean it just means that
uh the time scale of my control which
was one second should be faster than the
red and the variability of the system
the map ht
so if we want to go into faster
[Music]
then so basically if we just i mean
we can we can just assume that we do
one evaluation every time step which is
fine i think it also works
uh in practice it worked because what we
did really is we did this not
within the same step but we really
evaluated it one by one
and system changed in between so in
terms of performance i think it didn't
matter much again because there was not
much variability within one second
when we did it but if you want to
account for this variability
it could be done and i think we yeah in
the upcoming paper
we will be doing that by incorporating
uh these bounds on how much system
changed within one
step um incorporating them in the bound
in the in the convergence bond
in the tracking bound you can do it then
you will have another term with a
tracking
in the tracking bound you will have
another term here that represents this
variability
as well here this bound assumes that
there is no variability within one step
if you
assume there is then you will have
something here that that will account
for it so this is kind of the easy
answer to this but
um of course if you the faster your
system changes the less good this thing
will be right so basically i would say
the easy answer will be you need to
perform control in this probing of the
system
faster than it changes
good uh serenity is asking uh did you
compare the performance of the fully
centralized case of the fully
distributed case
i guess you haven't because you haven't
implemented the fully distributed case
or did you
uh like the price of anarchy in
game theory right like what's the cost
of fully decentralizing
have you implemented any of this
constances based target terms or any of
these ideas
uh have you experimented with that so by
fully decentralized do you mean
what so yeah i just want to uh it is
yeah like maybe you can observe your
neighbors and your neighbors can
you signals and whatnot this sort of
thing
yeah you know so the network phase so
maybe peer
peer to peer uh communication rather
than centralized
well and respecting the topology i guess
because
you don't expect to be able to
you know phone up like arbitrary units
yep
yeah we have we have another we have
actually developed algorithms for this
peer-to-peer communication
with the communication graph that is not
necessarily the topology of the system
but it could coincide or could not and
it depends sometimes
it doesn't have to be so you have a
communication graph and you have a
system
like physical system graph right so we
have algorithms that
um yeah i i can again i can send some
some uh some um yeah if you're on the
report
you could you could just point uh us to
some papers
uh on that i can put references inside
these
slides for example maybe yeah like
a reference to a slide yeah i mean i can
either put it on the
on the slides or where where would
whatever wherever you would like me to
i can add more references and yeah
whatever is best for
i'm not sure where it's better to put it
so
well there is this discussion thing uh
app that it would be ideal to put it
there
i mean in i this core server is like a
slack code
uh i give you access to it okay okay
yeah just let me know where and i can um
and then okay
and um okay so
next question what are interesting
applications other than power control
that uh this online feedback primary
dual argument would be good fit too
it's their main structure in the power
control problem that was exploited
yeah uh how specific is this t
fire control
well you know on the high level nothing
not much was exploited here right as you
can see
i was just saying we have a a um
an input output system and in the fully
this fully model-free case it was
basically
in the fully modified case we didn't
assume any structure
for the function h in the in the
previous version here we assume that at
least this jacobian here you can compute
which is kind of minor i know it's kind
of an assumption you can assume
but um but it is applicable to any
system
i would say uh other applications to be
considered
is communication networks we have
i think in one of the papers we have
some of these some of these examples
um you can apply it to other utility
networks such as water
gas networks similar problems can be
formulated there
when you try to control some of the
elements in the water network for
example
um and um wind farms actually this is
very interesting
application that sean is was mentioning
again wind farms are even more
complicated
kind of creatures right because the wind
farm itself
they can be interconnected by a network
but the wind farm itself is a creature
that is uh
unknown right you kind of need to probe
it and see how it works to make sure
that
you do something reasonable with it so
it's kind of another application so yeah
i think the kind of wide range of
applications if you can if you
if you are interested in this real-time
optimization and again their kind of
process of
there is tons of application in process
optimization for example i think
but the people already did it i guess
even before so
and uh okay um
oh yeah it seems that people are really
curious uh
um so two more questions and then then
we
call it to the answer that we can let
people go to sleep in europe and whatnot
um so ronnie is asking
uh physical noise shocks uh due to solar
and
volatility and whatnot have non-trivial
correlation structures
uh are you trying to account for
for these in some way like do you need
to
you know um take these into account
any specific consideration or special
considerations because these shocks
could be
you know have unusual characteristics i
guess
fat tails whatnot
[Music]
so so i guess it's more question of a
noise that is really abrupt
and have a high impact on the system
rather than just small
changes yeah it isn't correct
not here probably but yeah like
something abrupt and uh
yeah so so actually yeah so
again this kind of in the analysis it
comes just
it's a bit it looks bad in the analysis
because it will just come in the worst
case
sigma right remember sigma is the worst
case variability of the optimal
trajectory
so if you have a shock or you have
abrupt chain the signal will be very big
it means that
this thing will be probably useless
but in practice you can see that it can
happen also like here it's here
there was a shock so what happened here
there was an abrupt change in network
topology
and the voltage dropped in a step
fashion right
and what the algorithm did it just okay
he had to
it had to absorb this shock but it was
able to
bring the system back to stable
operation of course if the shocks are
happening
every second then what can we do right
so
yeah but okay it's enough enough time
between shocks or between these abrupt
changes you yeah somehow the time scares
will matter right yeah and you need to
know
some like you have to have some prior
information like
even the definition of the optimal
trajectory involves uh
expected the time scale constants right
right right right um so the final
question
uh determine um so could this be applied
to determine optimal pricing in two
sided platforms like
ride sharing platforms i'm sorry
can this be applied to determine optimal
pricing in two-sided platforms
yeah it's like you have two
types of agents interacting with each
other
the provider and consumer and you're
trying to set the price
well you can say that well yes that
probably requires some further thought
yeah i think it is it requires some i i
i need to understand the problem a bit
better let's say so
um but again uh it's
these metals again as they put here in
the slides the
the kind of useful if you have
a system that you want to optimize but
you don't know
what the system is going on what is
going on inside the system
but you are able to measure the mer
the outputs that are of interest right
and if they are
measured yeah fast yeah fast exactly so
fast enough to cope with changes in the
system if you're not able to measure if
you measure them once in an hour then
who cares right i mean
you're not gonna do anything but if
you're able to measure fast and you
don't know the system then then you can
do something otherwise
yeah and then if yeah if it fits then it
fits
so the answer is maybe yes maybe yes
yeah but
i will be interested to see that no the
problem because it's kind of interesting
i'm looking for more applications to
these yeah
i just sent you a private message with
the discord server address so you can
open that and then uh i ask people to
ask for the questions there and
and thank you very much for the very
interesting talk
um and let's call this uh today for
today
and i hope to see you uh everyone
tomorrow
all right so thank you andrei thank you
again thank you again for inviting me
that was very
very interesting
for us thank you thank you sean
bye